last week i think it was maybe the week
before apple had one of their usual
press conferences and they announced
their latest possibly last version of
the m1 chip which was the m1 ultra and
one of the things that they said as they
launched it was that they designed it
using two m1 max chips basically stuck
together using something called ultra
fusion to join them together now ultra
fusion is just a marketing buzzword
and literally all they've got is a high
speed interconnect between the two
silicon dies to transfer data between
them but one of the things that they
said which was interesting is that the
reason they'd done this
was so that you didn't have to write the
software in a different way and i
thought it was interesting just to pick
up on that and to explain
why if they hadn't made that
interconnect fast enough
you would have to write the software in
a different way because if you think
about it
all they seem to be doing is adding more
cores to the cpu making it a 20 core cpu
instead of a 10 core cpu and you think
well if it's a multi-processor system
and if you've watched the videos we've
done previously on multi-processor
systems you're going to have to write
the software to split the tasks up over
the multiple calls to run so why are you
not going to have to write things
differently with this architecture of
chip so i thought we'd have a look at
that today
so to understand what apple's done we
need to go back to basics and think
about how a computer actually works and
we'll go with the von neumann model i
know technically most modern cpus are
modified harvard architecture but the
von norman model is good for what we
want to look at we have at the center of
our system
the cpu
whatever we want
and that is then connected
to some
memory
and i'm just going to write ram here so
it fits into the box of course some of
it would be rom and other things and
then the other thing that we have in
there
is we have the i o
and things and that's basically the
model
we use for a computer we've got the cpu
talking to the ram where the
instructions and data are stored and you
can talk to the i o to talk to the rest
of the world so that's things like your
disk controllers whether solid state
hard disk your graphics card your
network card now what happens
when we have a multi-processor system
the general way that we build
multi-processor systems certainly the
ones that we use in laptops are using
desktop computers is using what's called
a shared memory model so just as before
with the von neumann architecture
we're going to have a single block of
ram
and that's going to be connected
not to one cpu now
but we'll give it
two cpus so we've got two
cpus that it's connected to so it's
connected to a shared bus between them
and then each of those cpus are
connected to it now effectively that's
how you build a multi-processor system
it's a bit more
involved for example you need some sort
of logic here
for bus
arbitration so we'll call that the ball
the bus arbitration logic so you need
something to sort of control well which
cpu can talk to the ram at any one point
now
one thing i need to say here is that
i've drawn this as the cpu talking
directly to the ram if you think about
it if you watch the video i did many
years ago on cpu caches
you need to have a cache here because
otherwise
only one cpu can ever talk to ram at the
same time
if there's no cache this cpu tries to
talk to ram this one can't if that's the
cpu tries to talk around that one can't
at the same time it would effectively
result in serializing the operation so
you wouldn't get any speed up you need a
cache in there
and that
sort of leads us to the first part of
the problem only one cpu can access the
ram at any one point now if we've got a
cache in our system and i'm going to
draw that as a red line which sits
between the cpu
and between the ram that's not a problem
because as the cpu accesses data it
stores a local copy in its cache so when
it needs to try and fetch that data all
those instructions again it can fetch
them from the cache
and not access the ram
so that's absolutely fine
most of the time we want to get it so
the cpus are satisfying their data and
instruction fetches from the cache and
then only occasionally they go to the
ram so that actually whenever one of the
cpu goes to the ram needs to go to the
main memory to fetch a value then
effectively it's unlikely to be being
used by the other occasionally you'll
get the situation where they both try
and access a value in main memory at the
same time at which point that's why you
have the bus arbitration logic to say
this cpu is going to fetch the value
then that cpu is going to fetch the
value so we can build a shared memory
multi-processor system like that
i'm going to say relatively
straightforwardly there's a lot involved
but
that's the basic idea of what's going on
and we can extend that to have more cpus
so we can just add another cpu in
up here so we could have a three cpu
system
normally probably go up to four and
things but i've run out of paper it's
got its cache as well and you can extend
that for as many cpus as you like
except
there is a slight issue
we said that
there are occasions where one cpu might
be trying to access the memory at the
same time as another cpu
hopefully we can build the cache system
we can bit load more data than we need
each time we fetch things and so on we
can build an intelligent memory system
that can satisfy this so that the
probability of that happening is
relatively low but if we think about it
if we add more and more cpus
onto the same shared memory bus
then we're going to end up with more
chance
of a collision happening of two cpus
trying to access memory at the same time
and the caches on each cpu mitigate that
to some effect so that they reduce the
probability of two things trying to
access at a time
but a bit like the old birthday problem
you know the sort of question you ask if
you've got a class of school children
what is the probability that two of them
share a birthday in there turns out it's
quite likely once you get above about 20
or so children in the class
the same thing applies here as you
increase more cpus the chance that two
of them will try and access memory at
the same time
increases
as you add more cpus
and so this will scale a scale but it
will only scale up to a point once you
get past a certain number of cpus
you will find that you're back to the
point where actually more
it's more likely than not
that two of them will be trying to
access memory at the same time
so we can scale this up to a certain
number of cpus so does that form a limit
is there a limit on how many cpus we can
have working together in the
multi-processor system
well not as such because there's another
way
we can design a multi-process system so
this is what's known as a uniform memory
access system and the reason it's known
as that is that for any location
in ram
any of these cpus can access it
with the same sort of speed so it
doesn't matter whether it's coming from
cpu one up here or cpu3 down here it'll
take the same amount of time for them to
access the value in that memory location
um different memory locations may have
different speeds your rom might be
slower than the ram
you may have things mapped in there
which are slower still and so on but for
any particular memory location each cpu
can access it in the same time all
within the same nanosecond ballpark so
it makes no difference
in reality as we said that will scale up
to a certain number of cpus but if we
want to take it to beyond that
then we need to change that system we
need to build a system that no longer
has
uniform memory access rather than from a
memory location each cpu being able to
access at the same speed
for each memory location the speed it
takes to access it or how long it takes
for it to access the data value there
depends on which cpu core is trying to
access it so it might be that for one
cpu core
it takes
i don't know let's say
100 nanoseconds just picking a time off
the top of my head but for another cpu
core it takes 200 nanoseconds they're
just ballpark times they're not older
magnitude just shows there's a
difference
between the two okay let's have a look
at how we build a system like that so
what we're talking about is what's
referred to
as a non-uniform
memory access system so non-uniform
memory access
system or numer
for short so how does that differ well
let's think about it it starts off in
the same way we have a block of ram
i'm going to turn the diagram around
ram like that and that is connected
to our cpus just as before i'm missing
out the caches and the arbitration logic
from this diagram just for simplicity so
this looks relatively similar to what we
had before we've got a some ram and some
cpu calls to sharing access to it no
difference there with a numerous system
though we also have
some other ram
that's part of our system connected to a
different set of cpu cores
over here now at this point you've got
effectively two computer systems these
cpus can access this ram these cpus can
access this ramp the difference in the
numa system is that there is actually a
link
between the two
systems here and you've got a
distributed
shared memory system think of it like a
sort of network but it's often done at
the cpu level and things even within on
some between cores now what this means
is as far as the program's running there
is one block of memory there so this is
if this was 16 gig
and this was 16 gig the programs would
see 32 gigabytes they're not separate
blocks of memory uh they're seen by the
programs as one block of memory
but the difference is is if we've got a
program running on this cpu over here
it's got direct access to this block of
memory here
so let's say it takes i don't know let's
say it takes
100 nanoseconds again to access memory
so we've got 100 nanoseconds to access
money if he wants to access memory in
here
it will take 100 nanoseconds to access
that memory value
but if the data it's trying to access
is over in this memory over here
a cpu over here could access it in 100
nanoseconds
but for this cpu over here cpu over here
it's got to go over this distributed
shared memory connection
from this set of ram and this set of
cpus to this set of ram and this set of
cpu cores over here
and that would take
a significant amount of time i mean it
would take 100 nanoseconds over here to
get from here to here
so to get from here to here plus this
let's say this is 200 nanoseconds i'm
just making a number up of here it's a
longer
amount of time i'm making these numbers
off of the top of my head so don't take
them as any sort of things other than so
it's longer to go from here over here so
we'd have to go over here
across the distributed shared memory
link
to get the value and then we could bring
the value back so rather than taking 100
nanoseconds it would take in the order
of 300 nanoseconds it will take a
significantly longer amount of time so
if you build a computer system like this
we have the situation where depending
where an instruction is in memory or
where data is in memory it could either
access it very very quickly on this cpu
core if it can go directly to the ram
that it's directly connected to
or it would end up taking a long time
relatively to access it because it'd
have to go over the shared link and
fetch it from the other block of ram
over there it would still appear to be
the same memory system but we've now got
the situation where the access to it
depends
on which cpu is trying to access it so
we have what's called a non-uniform
memory access system now originally
non-uniform memory access systems were
the sort of domain of high-end cluster
systems sort of sgi type workstations
and things but these days you've
actually seen it drop down onto sort of
workstation type machines some of the
amd threadrippers some of the higher end
intel presses or all
pneuma based systems and what this means
is if you want to run that cpu at the
fastest possible speed
you need to write your software
to take into account
which cpus have fast access to which
bits of ram
so that you can put the data that those
cpus are processing and you can put the
instructions that they're running in
that block of memory and have the cpu
date the cpu instructions and the data
that's being executed on these cpus
in this block of memory over here so
they can all access it very very quickly
and you only have a very small amount of
data which is needed to synchronize
things and keep things working passing
over the shared memory network
now you can do it and it works great
but you have to write your software
knowing where things are in fact if you
look you can find papers and
presentations from companies like
netflix where they're really trying to
optimize the performance of their
servers to serve the videos to you i'm
sure youtube's doing the same as well
but netflix have actually written about
it really optimize the speed of serving
the videos to you so they actually have
to take into all this account so that
the network card is connected to one
cpu
gets that data and doesn't have to go
and pass it over the shared memory link
to another one which then passes it over
to another one to fetch the data from a
hard disk and so on and feed it back to
you and you get everything's passing
over the slow link all the time you
really have to take into account
where things are
which brings us back to apple's
marketing buzzword of m1 ultra fusion
what have apple done with m1 ultra
fusion well effectively they have built
a system like this they've taken two m1
max chips
and glued them together so you've got
two 10 core m1 max chips each accessing
their own blocks of memory or two blocks
each which is why you can get up to 128
gig on there because you've doubled the
amount of cpu cores you can double the
amount of memory
that they can access and what they've
built in the middle the thing they call
ultrafusion is just a very very fast
distributed shared memory link between
the two
and i think what they've actually done
is they've just made it so fast that
actually the time it takes to go across
from one cpu core to the other to get
the value from the ram and push it back
into the cpu
is so quick the latency is so low that
effectively
it behaves as if it was a uniform memory
access system it's fast enough that when
the cpu requests the data it gets it
before it actually needs it and which
point it doesn't slow it down
so it's a nice system because it means
as a programmer we don't have to worry
about where
the data is in relation to the cpu cores
which one's attached to which core and
things to make things run as pos run as
fast as possible we can just write our
programs like the operating system and
the design of the hardware sort out the
hard problems of executing it as fast as
possible
chunks
and do them all at the same time
so
one way for example to make sandwiches
faster is that you butter the bread
faster you put the filling in faster you
put the bread faster the other person
analysis of where i went wrong says fred
brooks why did he make his name with
that and what was it all about